[Music]
today uh we quite happily cancel hookup
culture um but i'm not the one canceling
it not by myself anyway for today i i
join hands with pro-abortion feminists
in delivering this cancellation
ironically the anti-hookup culture cause
makes for strange bedfellows so in
response to the termination of roe v
wade the reaction from abortion
enthusiasts has stretched across the
whorishness spectrum in many cities
around the country protesters who skimp
on clothing but never on meals have
defiantly paraded their half-naked
bodies around oftentimes twerking
aggressively like some kind of weird and
ghastly mating ritual here was the scene
in dallas for example check it out
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if anything could ever make me mourn the
end of row uh it would be a scene like
that
but row itself was such a monstrosity
that even these sorts of nightmarish
spectacles are a cost worth paying
watching that video i don't regret that
roe was overturned but i do perhaps
regret that i am not blind but in any
case here we have women wielding their
sexuality as a weapon it's just not
clear what the weapon is supposed to
accomplish or what it's supposed to
destroy besides their dignity and my
appetite but on the other end of the
spectrum
some pro-abortion women have gone an
entirely different route rather than
bending over and presenting themselves
to the public like a dog in heat these
women have promised a sex strike
they're saying that they will for a
period of time or maybe forever
stop having sex with random men in order
to punish those random men
for the supreme court's decision
it's not clear what these men have done
to deserve that punishment but i'm sure
they're grateful for it anyway in one
popular video on tick tock an abortion
fan lays out the plan specifically
listen
hear me out what if we withhold sex
i'm not kidding what if we use our most
powerful protesting option
and withhold sex from penises
until this is made right
i love that i'm not kidding part because
she the idea of withholding sex of like
not having sex or abstaining
to hurt it's so you know of not having
sex with random people all the time it's
so shocking to her that she has to pause
she said
here's an idea what if we don't have sex
for a while no seriously i'm not kidding
seriously guys
withhold sex from penises she says
because that's how she views the sexual
act as an exchange between two sets of
faceless nameless body parts the new
york post talked to some protesters at a
demonstration in new york city about
their sex strike plans
and they all hit on similar themes
reading now it says
big apple abortion protesters were in
support of a sex strike saturday as
abstinence started trending on twitter
in the wake of the supreme court's
decision to overturn roe v wade quote if
you're a man who won't get a vasectomy
even though it's reversible and you're
not out on the streets fighting for my
rights uh you don't deserve to have sex
with me brianna campbell a 24 year old
emt told the post caroline healy a 22
year old event coordinator also
questioned why sex was more important
than women's rights quote i think it's
absolutely valid for us to be
withholding the holy grail that men seem
to think is important she told the post
quote women of america take the pledge
because scotus overturned roe v wade we
cannot take the risk of an unintended
pregnancy therefore we will not have sex
with any men including our husbands
unless we are trying to become pregnant
one twitter user wrote i live in new
york quote and i am double furious with
the supreme court i want to find people
who are coordinating a mass sex strike
that is our power one woman raged quote
women have the power here no more sex
until abortion rights are federal law
another said quote perhaps a sex strike
also known as abstinence would help the
men folk to be all in on the women's
rights issue
well um
i am a man folk and i can say that your
decision to abstain from sex in response
to overturning roe
definitely does not make me lament the
overturning of roe it is rather a
significant bonus this is like this is
like getting upgraded to first class and
then finding a 100 bill under your seat
okay this is this is again upside upon
upside win upon win
and we're not done winning it because
back on tick tock the pro abortion
luminaries of that app have been even
more explicit about their ultimate
intentions
reading from an article on insider
published a few weeks before the road
decision was officially announced it
says quote some women say they will deny
casual sex if they do not have abortion
rights after news broke the supreme
court uh is poised to overturn roe v
wade quote in case you're a man who
doesn't care about roe v wade just know
that if abortion gets banned hookup
culture will be absolutely decimated
according to one tick tock user which
has received more than 1.2 million views
in a single day
quote what women what woman would have
mediocre sex with a drunk rando if he
could potentially father their child she
continued noting that the video is
directed at all the pro-life men who
love plan b
the clip drew more than 263 000 likes
and more than 3 100 comments with many
users agreeing with her assessment quote
omg i'm entering my celibacy era a user
commented below to which the video
creator replied that she had the same
thought the second the news came out
we all need to collectively agree to
never touch another man again if it gets
overturned
another user declared that they were
deleting all dating apps as we speak in
another video which received twelve
thousand views fitness influencer nikki
cox said that the debate surrounding roe
v wade isn't just for women quote since
about 75 of men only care about sex and
money i hope they know this roe v wade
decision could destroy hookup culture
and leave them paying 18 years of child
support she wrote
now
one thing you'll notice is that over the
past few days
the pretense has been completely dropped
abortion advocates are no longer
pretending that abortion is anything but
a form of birth control
of course prior to the overturning of
roe they bristled at the suggestion that
anyone would ever use abortion as birth
control
now amid their hysteria they've
forgotten about that talking point
altogether that's for the best
because abortion in the lion's share of
cases has been used as a means to
divorce sex from its natural
consequences
otherwise known as birth control
this has been the left's primary
undertaking it's animating principle
it's great commission
i think quite possibly this is more than
anything else
the core of leftism itself and that is
the desire to reduce sex
down to its mere physical sensations
they want to remove everything from the
sexual act except the physical pleasure
everything else goes away take away love
take away joy devotion fidelity
they want intimacy without intimacy take
away commitment familiarity emotional
fulfillment
and most of all or at least first of all
they seek to strip from sex it's
life-giving capacities
the problem they always run into though
is that it's not actually possible to
permanently remove all of those things
from sex
and if ever they do encounter somebody
usually a man who's actually achieves
the goal of engaging the sexual act
without any emotions or any sense of
responsibility or any commitment at all
wrapped up into it
they'll hate that man and organize a me
too mob to come after him
because as usual they don't much like
the frankensteins they've created but in
most cases
totally emotionless and consequence-free
sex is an illusion
the attempt to neuter sex in this way to
turn it into a meaningless interaction
between nameless sets of sex organs
just creates a mass orgy of confusion
and despair otherwise known as hookup
culture
and yet even though hookup culture
utterly fails to make anybody happy
and instead succeeds in making everyone
lonely and miserable
it was still able to linger on as long
as it had abortion as its fail-safe
because abortion was supposed to be sort
of the fortress
defending the individual from the
natural results of their own choices
meanwhile inside that fortress everybody
is sad and confused and leading small
pathetic self-centered little lives
but but that's the way it was set up
and now the fortress has been weakened
there are cracks and gaps all around
where consequence
in the form of new life
can rush in
some pro-abortion people have decided
that the only way forward is to abandon
the fortress completely
give up on hookup culture
stop trying to have sex without
consequence
and this is the right response even if
they don't have the right motivations
behind it
and who knows
maybe if they give up on hookup culture
you know
then they'll discover that that what
they were trying to protect themselves
from
is much better than what they were
trying to protect
perhaps they'll abandon their pursuit of
consequence-free loveless pointless sex
and learn to embrace the alternative
and the alternative is not celibacy but
a committed
faithful relationship with another human
being who you know and love and who
you've devoted yourself to through the
bonds of marriage and to whom you can
give yourself fully and completely
without fear or reservation
and when you encounter the natural
consequence of sex the formation of a
new human life
you'll learn to see it not so much as a
consequence
but as a blessing
and a gift
with this perspective and this attitude
of true acceptance
you'll also experience what is known as
joy
which is something that you'll never
find in hookup culture
which is anyway today canceled
well before you go uh hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated
you